our county credit union
[Music]
well think of the most exotic places
you'll find formula one races austria
moraine italy spain netherlands russia
mexico china brazil abu dhabi montreal
you also may be allowed las vegas that
list as soon as 2023 there is a group of
las vegas heading to austin texas for
this weekend's race to discuss the
possibility of bringing f1 races to las
vegas and they'd race right here on the
world famous strip formula one is
expanding next year into miami and why
not las vegas it's an international
event with eyeballs from all over the
world watching and after all this is the
sports entertainment capital of the
world if las vegas is looking for
exposure and putting heads in beds
formula one might be the ideal pit stop
well think how thrilled you'd be if you
were named head coach of the raiders
after having never been a head coach and
you go out and win your first game rich
versace is dealing with those emotions
today after nearly 40 years of coaching
and in that business he finally gets the
opportunity to call shots as a head
coach credit mark davis and mike mayok
for allowing versace to take reins of
the program
he says like there's no int the two
coordinators gus bradley greg olsen also
helped make it all happen to come out
and have the first drive go down and
score in the last drive before the half
to go down and get the points you know
the big play to kenyan um in the corner
and then obviously the first play on
offense of the of the second half to get
points so i think they came out with a
good plan
raiders derek carr had a big game on
sunday the veteran quarterback had seven
pass plays it gained 25 yards or more
now according to josh durbo with the
associated press that's the most big
gains in a single game dating back to
1991. raiders previous high was four of
25 yards or more that was back in 2012.
credit card and company for taking
chances because it paid off as the
raiders rolled to an easy win over
denver
we're always looking to push the ball
down the field you know
you know especially you know especially
with guys like henry and brian and
waller
and we have guys that we believe that
can go do that kind of stuff so we're
we're always looking for ways you
obviously see plays that you know happen
on film
all right that's apparently it's working
right here for the raiders back home
sunday facing the eagles it's a one
o'clock kickoff over to legion stadium
golden knights are skating into the eye
of the storm this week three games
against some pretty good teams the blues
oilers and isles all visit vegas vegas
golden knights are coming off their
worst loss so how about this the kings
beat them up pretty badly in la maybe
they wish they could get right back on
the ice to remove that bad taste they've
got to wait until wednesday when they
face the blues
i think we talked about that the time
between games was probably important for
us as a group
to start getting some bodies back
now those guys are out there today woz
in a non-contact jersey
although we did everything
so you know hopeful they
feel good tomorrow and can take another
step and potentially ready for wednesday
earlier tonight we debuted our weekly
segment with derrick england we asked
him
with flourish mint and reefs gone who's
left to keep things loose in that locker
room
if you're looking for that guy that's
going to be loud obnoxious all the time
you know you can't look further than
marchy you know he's a he's a he's a
smaller guy but he is a big voice in the
locker room and
all right lots of fun there every monday
with derek england hey here's a great
news for our money league baseball
players here starting in 2022 teams will
pay players for housing according to
espn each major league team will provide
housing to players either in a stipend
or to cover lodging here in las vegas
the average aaa player makes about 700
and we will be right back